je propose de terminer les missions avec
un sujet un peu plus léger peut-être
naître qui vous pas miami ce week-end
donc vous n'avez pas pu voir l'art basel
qui était une manifestation d'art
contemporain extrêmement réputé et il y
avait notamment comme veuve re c'est
comme ça qu'on dit j'imagine exposé une
banane une vraie banana avec un ruban
adhésif
cette installation est l'oeuvre d'un
artiste contemporain italien très connu
qui s'appelle maurizio cattelan au
captage sait pas très bien comment
comment en prenant et figurez vous que
ça vaut 100 à 1000 $ et que d'ailleurs
ça a été acheté par l'une des
fondatrices d'un magasin branché par
exemple simple colette et alors ce qui
est amusant c'est que il ya un autre
artiste qui est arrivé pendant
l'exposition et qui à manger la banane
vous le voyez sur les images il
s'appelle lui david date une et c'est un
américain et il a expliqué que ça aussi
c'était une performance artistique
ivan rioufol ans vit une époque
formidable je sais pas je ne sais pas je
ne n'arrive pas à commenter cette image
je comprends pas le mot piège à con me
semblerait pardon de la vulgarité mais
assez pour ainsi représentative de ce
que loana ce à quoi on assiste
ça fait maintenant le ready-made c'est
quelque chose qui a été inventé en 1914
avec marcel duchamp vous savez qu'il
réprouvait proposer une grille noire
puis une roue de bicyclette puis importe
bouteilles en disant ceci sont des
oeuvres d'art ce que je décide - artiste
que ce sont des oeuvres d'art bon
c'était en 14
c'était très bien que monde a applaudi à
cette grande assez grande audace sauf
que maintenant on tombe à toi la roma
mais selon répercute à chaque fois ce
processus là et vous avez plein
d'artistes présents du artistes qui se
dit artiste parce que il met aujourd'hui
une banane en disant ceci n'est pas une
banane c'est une oeuvre d'art mais là on
arrive au summum du ridicule et
effectivement on peut manger la banane
donc on peut perdre de l'argent pour
pour rien donc je ne sais pas à qui ce
qui se prêtent à ce jeu là c'est un jeu
très spéculatif en plus ce serait
pervers que vous en pensez vous aimez
l'art contemporain venons mais alors la
demande et parce que j'en pense je ne
sais pas
j'ai déjà le fait que ça puisse valoir
san mamés d'or c'est déjà une forme
d'art non parce que là ça vaut déjà plus
rien à ce qu'il est
alors voilà je précise je reprend la
parole un instant compte effectivement
il ya plusieurs exemplaires de cette
oeuvre peut-être le temps de co2 banane
dans le régime je ne sais pas et donc
c'est pas grave pour la chanteuse
puisqu'elle fait elle va en avoir une
autre
et l'artiste et sa galerie ont décidé de
ne pas poursuivre l'homme qui avait
mangé la banane en trouvant que ce
n'était pas grave je vous passe la
parole mais je pense que ça fait partie
de l'ensemble en fait ce sont dans les
120 me lie à la fois la pose de deux
l'objet ce convoi l'objet et puis il ya
la performance comme il l'appelle de
celui qui vient manger la banane sinon
le tout n'est pas complet en plus ces
neuf qui va et évolutif parce que là
cette tête là aujourd'hui la banane et
elle n'aura pas bientôt donc
est-ce qu'elle sera encore revendu 100
voire 1000 euros si elle était ou est ce
qu'elle va perdre de sa valeur fait même
qu'elle va enfin tout seul non mais
enfin pour être très honnête je ne sais
pas trop on a va là des phénomènes un
peu comme ça qui sont en place qui sont
un peu irrationnel quand même parce que
ça pourrait être à la fois exploser ou
ne pas l'être dans un moment qui à
maurizio 4 la main mais j'en connais pas
le premier artiste comme ça qui sait
mais peu importe en tant que offre enfin
je suis toujours en tant qu'élu local un
peu interpellé par ce que je vois dans
les ventes
et dans ses expositions et quand
j'entends les besoins que j'ai
d'artistes qui ont besoin parfois et de
créer de ce pro de produire et de
trouver des lieux d'exposition et pour
lesquelles on a beaucoup de mal je
voulais je sais que je vais à paris
parce qu'il a explosé je fais je
n'aurais pas papa papa dont pas failli à
la mairie en mai je suis tu je suis
toujours je suis toujours arrêté voilà
et comme je lai dans un autre domaine
avec le football quand je vois les
montants des transferts et que je vois
la réalité des petits clubs dans les
villages où les provinces et quand je
vois
voilà les réalités artistiques et puis
celle du quotidien je suis tout j'ai
toujours un peu ce moment qui me met mal
à l'aise c'est la vie je l'entends mais
voilà je ne suis pas enthousiaste
guillaume pour ce coup là sur la banane
que vous exposer nos internautes non
plus un considérez vous la balade
scotché un mur et qui ne posait samedi à
miami comme une oeuvre d'art et bien
vous êtes 93 % à considérer que non mais
quand même 7 % oui
romain nous dit en tant que peintre de
métier je me suis toujours amusé je suis
toujours amusé pardon par cette
décadence
après les gens ont un oeil médusé de
tout autre création et philippe qui dit
en rigolant j'ai quelques photos des
extincteurs du grand palais lors de la
fiac plus exactement alors à charles ix
décida qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça et voit quand même si
après tout il ya des gens qui sont prêts
à payer ce prix là c'est parce qu'il se
passe quelque chose peut-être avec cette
banale c'est cette culture du buzz pour
moi on est on est vraiment on est en
train d'acheter quelque chose de alors
je crois que justement maurizio cattelan
avait dit que l'idée n'était pas de
laisser mûrir la banane au contraire
qu'il fallait la remplacer souvent il
peut donc voilà l'artiste et que donc du
coup le geste de
de la personne qu'il a à manger était
une manière de prouver que cette oeuvre
est évolutif puisque on pouvait changer
la banane régulière donc moi je crois
qu'on touche un petit peu au fin fond du
ridicule et moi ce qui m'a attaché dans
les artistes c'est justement qu'on avait
la bohème de charles aznavour on avait
le sentiment que l'artiste était dans le
besoin donner toute sa vie à son oeuvre
alors que aujourd'hui s'il peut gagner
120 mille dollars avec une banane on a
peut-être un petit peu moins envie
d'aider la bohème
aujourd'hui donc c'est un peu dommage
football - attachant et peut-être moins
artistique au sens de la lutte pour
arriver à quelque chose qui vous dépasse
je suis un peu déçu voilà jacky isabello
ghz et maurizio cattelan c'est un
artiste connu exactement qui avait fait
sept représentations hyperréaliste de
jean paul 2 à l'aller il avait reçu une
sorte de météorites et surtout un
portrait moi je les ai vus j'étais à la
monnaie de paris vous avez un petit
enfant qui à genouillé comme ça qu'est
ce que c'est vous et vous passez de
l'autre côté il à la figure de 8 l'heure
et je sais ça vous saisit comme ça vous
j'ai rarement été saisi par un artiste
alors moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec vous tant mieux parce que rappelez
vous quand yves klein a décidé de vendre
ce qu'ils appellent les autres de
sensibilité picturale mateille il a
vendu 120 mille balles alors parce que
c'était des anciens francs des boues des
espaces vides au dessus de pompe à paris
et puis il avait créé un simulacre où il
lançait une partie de l'or dans la scène
donc c'était le concept une dame parce
que moi je comprenais rien non plus j'ai
lu un jour un bouquin l'unm qui
s'appelle haute de queiroz qui ne fait
s'ils avaient de la géopolitique de la
elle dit vous savez là je parlais des
retraites tout à l'heure elle dit
maintenant l'ars et financiarisée c'est
un investissement comme un autre et elle
dit avant le chef-d'oeuvre c'était le
barbare partait avec votre chef-d'oeuvre
ils allaient le mettre chez vous chez
chez lui aujourd'hui c'est le concept
finalement qui se vend et quand maurizio
cattelan fait ça eh bien il fait du
chant il fait du clain là où il n'a pas
été très original paru sur catane
c'est que celui qui a écrit la plus
belle des chaussures sur la banane c'est
un artiste extrêmement connue
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle philippe
katerine rappelez vous de cette superbe
chanson il aurait dû demander à philippe
katerine de venir à miami pour manger
cette banane on aurait diffusé son
oeuvre
et là je pense que son coup de com
aurait été absolument parfait mais après
c'est à dire ça s'accouder
à 150000 euros d'après ce que j'ai lu
donc ce concept tel qu'il est
communiquée coûte 150 mille euros et il
va rentrer dans un portefeuille et il va
permettre à quelqu'un de s'enrichir de
payer moins d'impôts de valorisation ça
irait d'acheter ces gens de ce séjour
ardeurs j'ai l'impression qu'on va avoir
vous le même phénomène que pour les
emprunts russes c'est à dire qu'on va se
retrouver dans quelques années avec des
bananes a fait savoir qu'en faire
qu'elle vendra plus un clou ce sera très
bien fait moi c'est le fait de faire de
l'art une niche fiscale justement qui je
crois en lève un petit peu la partie de
soirée romancée de ski c'est la france
que vous êtes mans c'est 80 pour sûr que
c'est un lacet sont à prévoir
c'est un art fidal qu'il n'apporterait
rien dans l'expression artistique mais
qui apporte tout dans le discours que
vous mettez avec ce discours peu
d'importance est pas là donc c'est même
plus de l'art c'est même plus de
littérature ces deux-là jacasseries même
on a dit pareil des impressionnistes à
l'hebdo réceptive encore inclus j'aime
beaucoup
déjà qu'ils avaient loué pour ce que ce
sujet intéresse effectivement le livre
d'hôtes de queiros c'est très
intéressant c'était une nouvelle
géopolitique de l'art contemporain et ça
a été publié aux éditions eyrolles
voilà point de vue c'est fini pour ce
soir merci beaucoup à tous les quatre a
participé à notre émission et rendez
vous bien sûr demain à la même heure au
même endroit c'est à dire sur figaro
live bonsoir
[Musique]